le département a signé un financement
pour six projets destinés à
l'enseignement supérieur la recherche et
la formation médicale et scientifique
l'investissement le plus important celui
du rassemblement des centres de
recherche d'evry et palaiseau de l'école
des mines à versailles-satory ce
déménagement va nous permettre à la fois
de rejoindre un bâtiment très moderne et
très sobre mais surtout de rejoindre un
écosystème d'innovation à côté de
partenaires industriels deux partenaires
académiques très très de très grande
notoriété et également de lieu d'accueil
et de développement de start-up un
investissement estimé à 98 millions
d'euros montant global du projet 275
millions d'euros
pour l'instant le département assure
trois quarts du financement
il va de soi que si nous n'arrivions pas
à convaincre nos partenaires du contrat
de plan état région
participer à ce financement ce que nous
trouverions j'utilise un mot peut être
fort mais je le pense
scandaleux eh bien nous serions obligés
de mettre plus parmi des établissements
qui vont en bénéficier l'institut
d'études politiques de
saint-germain-en-laye 15 millions
d'euros pour soutenir des jeunes écoles
nées en 2014 ils vont servir à rénover
des bâtiments magnifiques qui relèvent
vraiment du patrimoine architectural
mais qui sont pour certains inutilisable
car beaucoup trop désuet c'est un
partenariat qui se renforcent qui se
tissent qui a commencé par le bâti et
puis qui est devenu beaucoup plus fort
et qui va là qui est important pour tous
les quatre projets restants concernent
l'iut de nantes mais aussi le
développement des pôles médicaux et
scientifiques à guyancourt et au bureau
portée notamment par l'université
versailles saint quentin